hey everybody Sean McGinnis and Peter
Brown here at PAX East 2014 and peter
has just checked out a new demo of the
evil within here at the Bethesda booth
Peter I saw a little bit of evil within
at e3 last year that whole sanitarium
demo yeah you saw that right yeah i saw
that then and that's here now for this
demo is well it's that same sort of like
dank foggy environment right got big
guides you know whole Kings got a big
club he's trying to hit you but what was
really cool was the new environment that
showed off which was a large city that
seemed to be succumbing to the effects
of an earthquake okay and so as you walk
around city blocks transform in front of
you and that sort of was what made the
scene really tense you know in the the
scene we described earlier it was sort
of like the darkness and this enemy that
was coming at you but here was the
environment that really played with your
your senses that's funny because
normally you think classic survival
horror you think haunted mansions
haunted hospitals haunted haunted
schools yeah not necessarily
environmental disasters right and you do
have those those seams you know aspects
where you have the zombies and things
like that coming after you but yeah it's
really about you know dealing with the
environment in front of you and just not
knowing what's gonna happen next there
was one moment specifically walking down
an alleyway where you had enough room to
run but then like the buildings would
start to sort of crumble and shift and
before you knew it you were like pressed
up against this wall trying to sort of
slide through it's actually kind of
reminiscent of the original resident
evil when that one of those first rooms
you walk into the ceiling starts coming
down on you right yes I seem sort of
like sense just like crap what's about
to happen but yeah no I mean I actually
really liked what I saw and it kind of
reminded me of Resident Evil both with
the sanitarium level with the sort of
indoor thing with the creepy monsters
and and but the outside stuff is pretty
much brand new or like I haven't seen
the present evil game do anything like
that before so I mean what's your
takeaway are you sold on this game
because I know a lot of people are kind
of split some people like the
atmospheric stuff some people don't seem
to like the combat very much what's your
takeaway here well the combat is it's
different right because you're facing
like light enemies and they're really
like hulking enemy is it take like a
bunch of shotgun blasts and that's not
interesting but when you're facing later
enemy is what's really fun is it fun you
uh so you know you take them down with a
shotgun blast right and then they're on
the ground and maybe they'll come and
bite you but what you do is you light
them with a match
and set him up right so this is really
kind of just brutal like you know
whatever it takes to take out your enemy
right so the combat is different than it
was in pastures and evil games and from
what I saw I thought it was kind of cool
and interesting but I haven't had a
chance to really play it that much so
yeah that would be the big question mark
right yeah all right cool so there you
guys have it that's your update on the
evil within here at PAX 2014 stay tuned
for a whole lot more coverage of all
sorts of games here over the weekend